I want to give you a signed copy of my
book okay guys so last week I announced
the contest where I'm gonna be giving
away one box ten books of my book
autographed special message limited
edition just for you guys
the contest is you need to create a
piece of art whatever your art is
whether it's a song a Photoshop file a
program you know whatever it is that you
do you make chairs make it one word
chair something that pays tribute to the
book in your voice your style your art I
want to see the creativity that believe
nation has I want to see your art and so
I mentioned it last week we've got it's
this is the last week this is it this is
all we have left the deadline is the end
of the year I want you to link up in the
comments of this video or last week's
video link up a link to your art so I
can see it and then we'll figure out who
gets the prizes will judge you they're
all judge or I'll have my team or a
believ national judge will figure it out
but sending your art I want you guys to
get the limited edition signed copy of
this book I signed a whole bunch of
books yesterday that are being popped in
the mail customized you know with a
special Christmas message for me so I
want to do that for you
I want you to be holding the book
personally signed by me as a reward for
the awesome art that you guys made okay
this is the last week to get it in
December 31st last date
we're not stretching into 2017 I'm
looking at it from that day and we're
gonna pick some winners let's get to the
shot see what you guys have to say first
up Nakuru I need 1/2 the key root let's
see your art give me something what you
got time to learn how to sing I want to
hear in the cue song on your one word
dedication give it to me to cure believe
nation wants to hear it bring it Joslin
hi Evan the book is the Singapore check
out this photo there we go we have our
first piece of art submitted I love it
your one word what is that building in
Singapore
I've been following Evan for the longest
time
this book let's read it this holidays I
love it thanks for that first piece is
in let's go guys keep submitting Jr eyes
dude yes art is for empires I love it
xeno still waiting for the book excited
I make sure to go to one Amsterdam's
landmark and take and share a picture
once I have it oh yeah I got to think of
something for the contest so you know
you got lots of creativity in there is a
know there's lots of creativity I want
to see something I need as a no piece of
art I want xeno infuse something around
your one word submitted link that up new
future builder awesome challenge
hmm I'm looking forward to the entries
and in terms of your other more mobile
platforms you should get yourself a used
phone or tablet that you just keep by
your desk or at EDS that way you can
play around with streaming the periscope
Facebook Instagram your gratitude stream
would do well in my opinion yeah maybe I
haven't done a ton of the live streams
except on YouTube I don't know I've been
in and out of snapchat I posted a few
things on snapchat here and there never
gets the lift that I'm looking for so I
don't know I'm still so much on YouTube
right now it's where I'm focused that I
don't know I don't want to be distracted
yet maybe 2017
you guys keep wanting it if you guys
really want me to be somewhere else let
me know I'll think about it
I'll think about it Miha Villa living in
a small town we actually have one
awesome landmark nice I'm looking
forward to it and the best link to buy
from in the UK's Book Depository calm I
appreciate that thank you for sharing my
hovel Steph I got the book it's awesome
see you soon I love it Steph is actually
coming in to film with me we're gonna do
an end special together we have a
special guest Steph Steph I want to see
some art bring it bring the art - akan
green guess I might make a silent short
film or something yeah silent short film
I want to see that link that up I want
to see your talent next up is Lane man
I'm whole hard instead of studying
political science and Mandarin I guess
there's no art I can make with those two
skills this is the thing guys this is
important entrepreneurship is about
being resourceful I want you to think
about how you can use your skills your
talents what you're interested in to do
something amazing if you're learning
Mandarin what's your one word and
Mandarin
can you write something in Mandarin
and read it for me that talks about your
one worked you make a video about that
can you talk about some of the lessons
in your one word and apply it to the
political theory in history that you are
learning and studying and where the most
relevant lesson is like that's art too
for me that's creation so I want you
guys to think about what is it that you
have to give what are you interested in
what is your passion it doesn't have to
be singing a song or making a photoshop
file you have art inside you that can
come out and I want to see it in the
context of your one word of the book
promotion somehow give it some tribute
it's important all of you have that
special something and I don't want you
thinking I don't have any talent to get
but I don't know how to express it
ask yourself instead of saying I can't
do this ask yourself how can I do this
that little shift not just for this book
but for everything all the things that
you tell yourself you can't do because
you didn't go to school for this or
whatever if you start moving from I
can't do this because I don't have the
skills to how can I do this get used to
asking yourself that constantly it's
game over your world is gonna explode
into amazing amazing things so yes
political science you can give me an
attribute Mandarin you can give me
attribute everything else you guys are
studying or interested in you can give
me attribute then I want to see it let's
link it up thank you for that lane
Kendra I'm so pumped about this
challenge five exclamation points I love
that Kendra I love that up at 2:46 am
thinking about how I can turn a garment
into a piece of art for your one word
book yes I want to see the your one word
garment I love that I love that Kendra
you have to do it you got a few more
days left you have to do it next up a
tool hey I've created an art image for
you to enter in this giveaway contest
please have a look thanks to the love a
tool thank you for the love keep it
coming guys more art link it up
who mesh I need one who mesh give me
some art that's the rule you need one
give me some art let's go to pond I want
one book I want a piece of art tap on
down below give me the link create
something amazing I want to see it I
want
sign a book and give it to you Tappan
you ever give me the reason just typing
it out I want one in the conference is
that enough art give me art link it up
be snob I want a book I want to know how
helpful the book will be to me I'm
excited to to know whatever is inside
the book I think the book will give more
knowledge to me for happy faces you know
what's gonna give me for happy faces
your art we get up below I'm gonna send
you a book I want all of us to be
smiling give me your art down below next
up mojo Andy pictures Evan actually want
a copy of your book a few weeks ago when
you were a guest on a radio show here in
Ocala I remember that show that was that
was a fun show I started reading and man
I got to tell you it's amazing yes I
love it man it's kind of ridiculous how
everything we love and everything we do
is linked and I didn't even realize it
until I started searching for my one
word thank you so much for this book you
say at the beginning that you want to
help 1 billion entrepreneurs well here's
one of them happy face thank you I love
it man I love it
listen give me some art I want to send
you a signed copy you can give one your
fret you can give the ocala one to your
friend you get the signed copy
give me some art link it up below let's
see it what else Nanda I need one Nanda
give me some art shadonna so I checked
out here in California burns a noble to
see if they have your books I'm going to
try and purchase one by next week to try
to make the deadline what it would be
nice if I can get a free one but I know
that's probably a chance of slim to none
but however I'm still interested in
seeing what all the hype is about so get
back with you once I get it hopefully
you found that book in Barnes & Noble
get inspired by it send it to marked the
theme of the day sand in art I want to
see it I want to see your Mandarin
tributes I want to see your
philosophical history tributes I want to
see your garment tributes your Photoshop
tributes your photography tributes your
song tributes your programming tributes
your dance tributes your kids paying
tribute something you got something guys
express it link it below jason bean i'm
sure you'll have some great entries
Jason Jason I want to see your grade
entry bro not to the others where's the
Jason bean entry let's link that up I
I'm gonna end it there guys thank you so
much for the love you know what I'm
gonna end with our heard link it up I'm
gifting you books autographed this book
is amazing it's gonna have a huge impact
on your life and your business I promise
you and you get it signed by me with a
special message you have a few more days
December 31st is the final day of entry
get to work get on your hustle
link it up below and hopefully I'll be
sending you a copy of your one word
signed by me in 2017 good luck guys
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love
I'll see you soon